the draw of Donald Trump
six years after he won the presidency
two years since he lost it The Show Goes
On
the vibe the energy The Branding at the
core it is all here
comes to command near total control of
today's Republican Party
he is their future
[Music]
honest uh he doesn't sugarcoat anything
he doesn't put up with anything and he
puts America first
the election was rigged and stolen and
we're not going to let it happen again
so from now on
for all that others have done to try to
discredit him to expose him as a crook
as a liar to confine him to history it
really doesn't feel as though
[Applause]
[Music]
hopes that this week's midterm elections
will confirm that his appeal stretches
well beyond this court that election
denying candidates he endorsed will win
foreign
even if one person here couldn't bear
the prospect
a lone protester who'd made it in
but then with her heckling and the
reaction
such deep angry divisions up close no to
your rally
with the former president still going in
the background She Was carted Out
all right
you just dropped my arm a little bit
okay
life is tough
big boys huh
we know full well that the election was
not stolen it was fair it was safe it
was Secure
I'm talking to you later she never did
tell us her name but she spoke for many
millions in the other America
they were up the road in this
battleground of a state a little earlier
where their hero was another former
president right now we've got folks
who's who's don't tell the truth well it
certainly feels like we're going back in
time but the Democrats clearly feel they
need the power of Obama they undergird
our democracy and that is at stake in
this election
it feels good to hear a sane speech from
politician that's measured and balanced
we can have two-party politics but it's
got to happen with respect and Civility
and that's not what's happening right
now
at times it is hard to see how these two
starkly different Visions for America
can be reconciled markstone Sky News in
Pennsylvania